what is up there reject nation here to
start act two of arcane season one
episode four happy progress day uh i get
a little breath of fresh air hopefully
it's gonna be so upbeat before we after
that last one guys all i asked right now
is that you go ahead and hit that like
button if you end up enjoying our video
or if you just want to be nice also
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next arcane episode is up as
always full length watch as long as we
sync up with the time code over at our
patreon page over there we cover seven
shows with the same tier you get the
reaction option option for the reaction
outlets to watch long included yes so
that's smoothly prepper thank you boys
writing this down for us let's get to it
[Music]
the council has recommended you give the
progress day speech this year but
you always give that speech
i i could never take your place
i agree with them
you deserve this honor
i will do my best to make piltover proud
professor but she won't give a better
speech
[Music]
i just want to jump in the screen
yeah
[Music]
warp speed
[Music]
we should have a progress day to
celebrate all of the progress we've made
in this great nation celebrate progress
not just achievements that's true hey
progress is underrated the visionary
behind the hex gates a beacon of trade
and prosperity for our great city of
progress who we very nearly exiled
well at least you'll have front-row
seats to the speech
speech
i'm giving the big
oh you're getting an ego buddy
[Music]
oh
no cool
what like crystals are fungus oh they're
like crystalline
you ever seen this much shimmer before
i like revolutionists yeah or something
are the revolutionaries or anarchists
[Music]
whoa damn
oh
bye
i can't lose you
[Music]
yeah
okay god what a reunion eh
[Music]
so she morphed into the ultimate badass
so metal i love it yeah
[Music]
cool that she's is she you're not dead
is she she
looks dead
you are supposed to guard the cargo
look how in control that she was until
she became so emotionally distraught
yeah all right but still remained a
badass good for you should you go buy
jinx now ah that's probably yeah hextech
was supposed to bring magic into the
life of the common man and now
it finally can oh
a hextech gemstone
[Music]
throw it hit it with a hammer
he's going to
we found a means to fortify the crystals
this new version is stable and
absolutely safe
that is revolutionary
we present to you
the next chapter of hextech
we can now design portable devices that
is a giant gauntlet
the atlas gauntlets
the mining colonies and the fissures can
work faster than without fatigue i mean
that gauntlet doesn't look very stable
yeah dude
get us
get another prototype going
a breakthrough like this takes time
victor putting that kind of power into
everyone's hands is dangerous i'm on his
side
oh man she's one of those cops yeah
since you're looking for more work you
can take the graveyard ship tonight at
the fair
yes sir
good i want this one on a boat to still
water prison so he's remained a dick all
these years yep no progress for him
one of those firelight wackos was a girl
with
pink hair
you're a lesbian
i understand i'm attracted to pink
haired women as well
i'm sorry
i need to know
that i can rely on you are they lovers
i get that sense
the only one actually worth my time is
him
the golden boy
oh he's one put over his heart
man of progress
everyone wants hextech for themselves
it's your speech
give the people a glimpse of the future
so we can make some money
it wasn't her
it wasn't
jeez
just just some wannabe street trash oh
she is like uber traumatized my mind is
fractured yeah
sufika will clean it up savika's
irregular johnny on the spot
she's turned into the joker yeah
that's like joker living in arkham
asylum
oh my god
no victor could use some hextech to cure
he's got the consumption
guess it's time
to drink it from his own mug yeah he's
got his own a little bit of an ego
progress guys am i right
i know many of you probably didn't
expect to see me here today and believe
me i'm just as shocked as you are
dude
gut buster over here
why does this feel ominous yeah this
can't go well
that we
will share with you
when the time is right
oh
things that will bring an end to your
hardships we vow to keep pressing
forward for we are the city of progress
and our future is bright
[Applause]
he's not showing us buddy i like what he
has to say
good intent
you know it's fair to celebrate the
progress you made in the past
oh
oh you lost your ally there
fire
fire
started a new fire let's try it
race to the other one
it's going to be the green goblin yeah
wrapped up in a in a sheet
and i hope that little girl and i set
the building on fire but
god what a nightmare
get out now
also i brought this dynamite
why did no one listen to her
oh she's becoming anarchist oh boy
i get why no one listened to her when
she said get out
the gemstone is gone
along with some of our research papers
wow
i have come before you to recommend that
we suspend all hex tech operations until
the situation is resolved including our
laboratories the refinery
and the hex gates but money it's
progress day perhaps the time has come
to explore a more
radical solution
assassins he's willing to sacrifice his
own enterprise and it seems to me only
mr talis has the knowledge necessary to
secure the hex gates
i propose that a new chair be brought
forward from the underground
let's take security should be
administered by a scientist
i second the motion
well then shall we vote
a seat at the high table
just like the joker and harley quinn
rolled into one yep
yeah there's one thing i've learned
about the council they need more than
just theories
since when did you concern yourself with
the council's opinion well
i don't need charity counsellor he was
all my parents
kate
get out get out of my very large room
that i got with my hard-earned dollars
as a cop
well there's been
an incident okay
[Music]
you'll be able to
as soon as he can move his jaw again
who assaulted him
was it violet yeah yeah
yeah violet dude
who the hell are you
cool nice
i was not expecting a time jump
you know what i i actually kind of was
oddly oh
oh
there he goes
there goes there's the great john
humphreys right that's right just oh
look the the old wise noise that's right
man here i am
i know what's coming in this show
the great predictor they call him
stands on top of the laurel canyon
mountains that's right
city of the valley spoilers
i'm about to proclaim the next
developments of the plot
i mean you know that's not
she looks familiar that jinx care like
in the design of older jinx i was like
oh
i might have seen you before
yeah yeah
damn that's crazy it's actually i i'd
imagine i have no idea what the
characters are like in the game yeah or
anything so
you know maybe it's not a surprise to
see
who powder evolved into
but for me
sitting here
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you went inside
you got traumatized but good
you're not then
the great the great job
can't remember the name of silko silko
see oh there you go there you go the
great greg you got you got hymer dinger
and silko in this episode i prefer
heisenberg heisenberg and sydney imagine
in this episode they just did a parody
of him the spoof character who just set
the hat and the sunglasses
i don't know about this chase
yeah yeah yeah he's
make them another decade
yes yeah i like it i'm the one who we
need more hecks
we need more progress
[Laughter]
yeah
i'm trying to cook these hexes
heimerdinger [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i want to reveal my progress today yo
they're ready to go now
anyway yeah
that was a cool episode it was it was a
bit of an adjustment for me because when
first you see cop lady i don't remember
her name for life i mean you know it
it's there or i don't remember it
i can see the subtitles but i can't uh
perform it in my mouth uh yeah when when
you first see her i was like oh
i remember being that old
yeah yeah yeah because i didn't realize
just how much progress they had made on
hextech
one you see uh uh you see our boy and
like he hasn't he doesn't he looks
exactly the same yeah exactly
yeah so and so so i was like oh okay i
don't know how much time has passed
maybe a few weeks or something because i
thought we were gonna see like the
progress of powder with uh
silko
and i thought when we see like a little
bit of a progress mara
kate kate kate caitlin caitlyn kkk
marta's actor's name okay so when you
when we first see the i thought we would
see the mid
i think she'd be like so manic and have
literally gone insane like you see the
designs she has in her little cave there
of the people whose lives she
accidentally killed yeah uh her her
former family you know like seeing all
that god and like effigies and the weird
freak out scribbles
it really does seem like joker and
harley quinn in
in like locked inside of arkham asylum
yeah like the prison of her own mind is
where she's trapped circa a little bit
of the joel schumacher like neon look
like you know
a little bit but uh you know appropriate
and not [ __ ] annoying
yeah yeah yeah yeah way more steampunk
and cyberpunk worked in yeah it looks
great it's it's awesome and then the
developments have seen silko how he's
taking over the underground taking over
for vander
and it just seems much more
like uh
seems more like criminal and debauchery
oh yeah yeah now it's now the whole
place is a club
like uh like a like a neon version of
zion from the matrix before it felt like
an understanding in a family of outcasts
yeah now it's like anyone would just
kill you here yeah
which seems like a like a like a hell
almost if you just imagine like just a
place of debauchery and where the city
of
say it john
[ __ ] what piltover ah damn not
piltovich piltover piltover the city
piltover this was probably the most
interesting it's ever been to me
uh watching the jace's storyline in
particular being more interesting to me
as well
because there's really see i like the
crossroads of the path that he's been
set in
where he's got heimdinger who's trying
to like slow him down in his tracks
things also dealing with the the
capitalism side yeah of it all and and
just how much of a
progress he's made for
our city but
it's like the intent and the
manipulation and what cost will this all
come at for the benefit of profit you
know yeah
so it's an interesting dichotomy for him
to be stuck in here and victor just
seemed so sick
so
so sick yeah i'm worried about it i feel
like he's gonna i feel like he's gonna
die at some point and send uh and send
uh
you know mr progress in a in a darker
direction there's a lot of batman
parallels i keep drawing here like the
caitlyn character reminds me of gordon
of a character who comes from a
well-to-do family and doesn't actually
need or am i getting gore to mix up with
someone else from well-to-do family i
don't remember now if gordon comes from
a well-to-do family
the great greg
greg greg with all the batman knowledge
what's going on gee i know barbara's
going on gee
diff one of his for his first wife did
come from the world today anyway
no you have no i don't think gordon did
either way that it is that cop more like
will smith from bad boys
yes well to do cop
uh who doesn't need this job but does it
because they [ __ ] care wants to be in
the action and they want to prove that
they're more than that so she's all
buffed out and doing the investigation
and uh
i like her
no i don't find myself exactly rooting
for her just yet you know i haven't
thus far i mean like it's cool to watch
her be competent in her job and it's
easy to relate to everyone around her
pushing her around and not taking her
you know
proactive
nature seriously but there's also yeah
like there's i'm waiting for something
else to get endeared to the character
other than just like oh yeah you're
you're jace's buddy and you're right and
you're doing the good thing yeah yeah
yeah it's like i'm i'm with you by
default but also i want to connect to
you as a character now yeah yeah so this
was like it's interesting seeing the
structure of this because
it's pretty much just a big setup for
what's going to happen with act 2. yeah
yeah yeah that's all we're really doing
is recapping what we learned
but i i think though what they have done
here they've i like the blend of the
tension that they brought with actually
watching piltover uh suffer some real
life consequences
for
uh after everything great that has
happened and then watching how this rise
of jinx and silko's
relationship how that seems like it's
going to cause a war this is everything
vander worried about like with
everything vander pretty much
um feared
you were watching the the rise of how
all that is going to lead they're
escalating now yeah and then also what
heimdinger's concerns are with magic
getting in the wrong hands and now it's
in the hands of silco i love they they
wasted no time with that yeah yeah so
there's a lot of great seeds planted
here and i really did enjoy the episode
a lot the time jump did kind of throw me
off a little bit because when we first
saw
is it put you in the shoes of
of of uh of powder or jinx put her in
the shoes of jinx so well
that when jinx shot
what looked like violet i was i was like
that must be violet because jinx looks
different so yeah maybe that's violet
right they're also aged yeah and so then
when the first second i had to do some
work around in my head of like
i can't believe they just killed that
violet like that
the hell
then it wasn't later until she was like
it wasn't violent it wasn't violent when
they were saying that yeah
oh
i thought that was violent
see i couldn't tell if that was that it
wasn't and she just had that moment or
if it was she was uncertain and
incapacitated her although it certainly
looked like that girl got murdered so oh
she's definitely dead dude she was full
on the ground yeah and i mean
looked pretty lethal but then yeah i'm
like okay then what's vi doing in jail
you know but but the crazy part is
she thought that was her sister
and she still shot her
yeah
she's she's it makes me curious now
what'll happen when they actually do
reunite
you know because uh i don't know it
seems like right now she is far gone
oh yeah like they pushed her over the
line so much that there's not even a
shade of i have hope for her
i know i don't like it's funny i don't
know even even going past this episode
other than you know in intense action i
don't know what to expect from jinx now
that's such a brilliant aspect to the
show because maybe if you have if you
play league of legends and maybe jinx is
this kind of character i have no idea
but as two people who aren't informed on
that
it's like a shock to go from who we last
saw her where i was like no
please
making fun of myself as if i wasn't
really like everybody happy
oh my god what happened to you my my
sweet little daughter are you scared of
you now
you're off the top of that rails dude
yeah yeah well it's effective that makes
it makes the time jump jarring and
enough in a really effective like
shocking way when you go from
they made you really care so much about
her too now she's like the ultimate
threat yeah it's almost it's almost like
uh it a shock of um
it hurts leads like an emotional
detachment for me and not in the way of
the show lost me it's in a way of i have
a hard time feeling
because i don't want to feel
i don't want to accept
especially after everything that led to
here yeah and also i mean her
relationship with silco i
i don't know what to make of that like
they have a very interesting like usual
yeah yeah and he's gotta be way older
than she is so and it's funny because
they don't
fully
they don't like kiss or anything but
they have like very intimate you know
but they constantly like touching and
being very close and she's like leaning
her head on him and i'm very curious to
see what what that is revealed to be as
things go forth because it seems like
there's more there than just
you're part of my crew
i don't know theater people behave like
that all the time they do they do and
that's awesome
has a thriving theater program that they
don't touch on in there underground gets
dull yeah there's no clue there's no
pill over but down here we got good
plates
but i like to the juxtaposition of the
time jump because you have jinx who is
so
who has had such a transformation and
you see where it comes from but it's
also very large and very uh garish and
very sort of unsettling
and then you cut over to jace and i
liked what they teetered with him
because you know we were joking
throughout this of like oh you're
getting kind of uh you know getting high
and mighty in your new status here but i
like that they kind of teetered on that
especially when he goes out and it's
like you know we're all rooting for him
it's funny because i was rooting for him
on the one hand to actually
you know
take another swing reveal the hex tech
and then he doesn't and i was it was it
was a wonderful way to be torn because i
was like this is probably the safe
choice because i have a feel like i
don't know i just got that feeling from
the scene i think you blurted that out
too it's like i feel like something
bad's about to happen
but i admittedly though there is
development that i would have liked to
have seen
yeah that's the part of the of time
jumps and especially in shows that can
bother me
is i would have liked to have seen kind
of the pro of how that relationship
unfolded with silco i would like to have
seen that cathartic moment felt it for
when jace is getting respect yeah
because
it's already happened yeah yeah it's
like a lot's happened i was like i would
have liked to have experienced some of
this
but it seems like for some other
characters who might not need to deal
with it
you know but it would have been cool to
see kind of the menacing rise of silko
too yeah how he's took over the
underground some kind of even even just
like a montage of yeah transitioning out
of vander's uh yeah zone into silcos
yeah there are things i was like oh i
wish we saw that i was looking forward
to seeing that but it also did such a
good job that i'm willing to accept uh
the stage that we're at right now yeah
absolutely
so more than one pack but guys what you
think about episode four leave your
thoughts down below we will get to
episode five and six this week
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button
i'm gonna assign john to raj krishnan
niraj krishnan i think you would come
from zahn because it rhymes with your
name but it's okay because you would
work your way up the ladder from the
dregs to the high society with piety i
don't know where all these rhymes are
coming from but i'm gonna see if i can
keep it up
rum tum tub second you point something
out
gets a lot harder to perpetuate
that
but niraj i can see you working your way
up the ladder becoming bigger and badder
than anybody below you getting drunk
with power
rising to the top and toppling the
system niraj you can't get carried away
with your technological advances don't
get too high and mighty all right you
might leave the patreon you might not
even need to be here and at that point
what are we gonna do we're just like the
people of zahn you're gonna neglect us
leave us for dead and then we're gonna
have to fend for ourselves and become
all bitter then come to where you live
and wreck the place and we don't want
that in a raj we don't want that at all
so keep your pledge man
and send us more music recommendations
because it's been a while it was good
thanks that was actually good oh hey
finally after a couple years it feels
good to get here
[Music]
you